Speaker 1: Let's go to Ryan from
New Hampshire. Ryan, welcome to
the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, can you hear me, David?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome.
So I just had a quick question. Kind of a theory,
almost. So with RFK Jr. More appealing to, like,
anti-vaccine voters and, like, moderates or sorry,
moderates who are less happy with Democrats. Yeah.
Do you see him to be, like, kind
of trying to do what Trump did,
where he appeals to like more fringe right
wing views and also more moderate people?
Speaker 1: I don't know that that's necessarily
what Trump tried to do. I think I mean, listen,
let me tell you what I do think about the
Bobby Kennedy. Like, what is his constituency?
Who who is it that would consider voting for
him? And I do think you're on to something,
which is it's slivers of both sides, which
isn't a good or bad thing. You could say, hey,
let me give you a hypothetical. Imagine you had
a candidate that was able to unite the part of
the left that is more progressive. On economic
issues, etc. and the part of the right that is
more into like a Chris Christie or John McCain who
realizes that MAGA is wrong. I would go. That's
great. That's a great alliance of left and right.
I think the issue with Bobby Kennedy is that he's
putting together a constituency that's not exactly
the best of right and left. It's arguably close
to the worst. It's the people on the left who
refuse to even consider that Joe Biden has done
some good things and potentially are anti-vaccine
or conspiracy theories on COVID or whatever the
case may be, as well as some of the right wing
people who are essentially MAGA people, but they
just don't know that Trump's the right vehicle for
their views. So he is, in a sense, uniting some
people from left and right, but it's not people
that I'm super impressed with as a constituency.
Speaker 2: If that's what was my concern was that
the kind of voters that he would get together,
I don't know how much they would agree with
voting with each other based on their views.
Speaker 1: Yeah, 100%. 100%. And listen,
we'll see. The guy's got 12 or so percent
on average. If you look at this like
that is something that is definitely
something. And we'll see what he does with it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it's just interesting for me to
see how he plans on going up against Joe Biden if
he gets there. It's just very interesting to me.
Speaker 1: That will be interesting to
see. All right, Ryan, thank you so much.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you,
everybody who called in. We're going to take
a break. We will take calls again. I can never
get to everybody, so please don't hate me for
it. I got emails, David, you didn't get to me.
I apologize. But let's take a break and then
the program will continue. Right after missing